♪
[Lee] Let's fly, baby!
[Barney] Brilliant!
♪ Can't stop ♪
(knife clangs)
(laser squeals)
(mysterious music)
[Lee] Welcome home, honey.
[Gina] Do you read now?
- What is this?
- It's classified.
- I'm comin' with you.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
You weren't invited.
- Oh.
♪ Bad, bad, bad behavior ♪
♪ Nothing can stop me ♪
♪ I can't get enough ♪
♪ Playing with danger
is bad behavior ♪
(knuckles crack)
- Oh.
♪ Bad, bad, bad behavior ♪
(door crashes)
♪ They call it bad behavior ♪
(logo booms)
(Barney knocks)
- Hey. Why are you here?
[Barney] I got this situation
where I need your help.
- I need better friends.
(logo crashes)
(mysterious music)
[Gunner] Is that the new guy?
[Easy] This our sniper?
- Don't worry about it.
I got a prescription scope.
- Look Hawk Eyes,
remember this face.
Don't shoot it by accident.
(both laugh)
[Marsh] Terrorists have
taken possession
of nuclear missiles
on a cargo ship off the coast.
♪ Let's go, let's go ♪
If these babies go off,
(soldier inhales)
it'll be World War III.
Shhh.
(guns click)
(lasers screech)
- Take cover!
(engine revs)
- You choose this life
over friends,
(fighter yells)
over family.
(motorcycle revs)
(bomb explodes)
- It's time to get loud.
(soldier screams)
(upbeat music)
- Let's fly, baby!
(logo crashes)
♪ Can't stop. Addicted
to the shindig ♪
- Come on. Bring it!
♪ He says I'm gonna win big ♪
♪ Choose not a life
of imitation ♪
♪ Distant cousin to
the reservation ♪
(car explodes)
- Now, that's what
I'm talkin' about.
♪ Can't stop, can't stop ♪
(fighters grunting)
(knife scraping)
[Suarto] Is that the biggest
one you've got?
(knife screeching)
[Toll] Oh, it's way bigger
than that.
(upbeat rock music)
(knife clangs)
(laser squeals)
(engine revs)
(logo crashes)